PETRIE-NORRIS AND WE'RE GONNA
CALL THE HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW I HAD TO
ORDER. AT THE FOR WE AT BEGAN.
LET ME JUST TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS AT FIRST I
TO ENSURE THAT MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA AND THE PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS
. NOTHING STRANGE MEANING YOU
KNOW TO HELP. ALL RIGHT THAT WE
WILL WE BEGIN AT GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME TO YOU AT TODAY'S
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLIES
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW. I BEFORE
WE BEGIN LET ME TOUCH ON A
COUPLE OF ADMINISTRATIVE POINTS
AT FIRST TO ENSURE MEMBERS OF
THE MEDIA AND THE PUBLIC HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY
THIS HEARING WILL BE STREAMED ON
THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN PERSON HERE
IN ROOM. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN
OR ON OUR TELEPHONE LINES ARE
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM TODAY
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
ARE REQUIRING PHYSICAL TESTS.
PLEASE FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OUR
REGIONS AND POSTED GUIDANCE. I
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WITH LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL OR INFORMATIONAL ITEM I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR PHONE TESTAMENT MANY
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WILL BE PROVIDING COMMENT
VIA TELEPHONE. WE ARE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
TODAY. THE CALLING NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE PEN IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. PLEASE CALL
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
BEGINS THEIR PRESENTATION. AT
THAT POINT THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE
JUST A REMINDER THAT IF YOU ARE
CALLING AND- PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST. AND ANY OTHER
DEVICES. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH MODERATE IF SEVEN
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE SIX. AND
LASTLY I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND FOR
PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
ALL VOICES ARE HEARD HOWEVER
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS AND
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT AT THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR COOPERATION. UP
WITH THAT. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS HERE NINE
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESIDENT
PATTERSON PATTERSON PRESENT AT
GREAT. LACKEY THEIR PRESENCE
MEDINA. PRESIDENT RODRIGUEZ NOT
PRESIDENT. ALL RIGHT SO WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM THAT WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND PROCEED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. NOT WITH THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS- I WANT- FIRST
START BY SAYING THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US
TO- IMPROVE THE BILL AB EIGHTEEN
OH FOUR AS A SIMPLE A GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL THAT WILL
IMPLEMENT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THE FENCE CAL PROJECT-
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
STRENGTHENING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND CREATING
INDEPENDENCE WITH HOW FITS CAL.
CONTRACTS FOR ITS OVERSIGHT
SERVICES THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
JOHN LEWIS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE- WHERE WORKED
WITH ANA THIS REPORT. WONDERFUL
I'D THAT. OPERATOR CAN YOU GO
AHEAD AND OPEN THE LINE FOR
MISTER LEWIS. MR LEWIS'S LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING I CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN LEWIS I
AM AN HONOR PRINCIPLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE- AS YOU'RE AWARE OUR
OFFICE DOES NOT TAKE A POSITION
ON PROPOSED LEGISLATION BUT I'M
HERE TO COMMENT THAT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU KNOW FOR ADDRESSES
SOME CONCERNS THAT WE GRANT
IMPLEMENTS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MAKE REGARDING THIS GAL. THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE MONITORS
THE FISCAL PROJECT EMISSIONS
MONITORING REPORT AT LEAST
ANNUALLY FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS WE'VE OBSERVED THAT THE
FISCAL PROJECT IS REDEFINED WHEN
THE PROJECT WILL BE OFFICIALLY
COMPLETE AND IT WILL NOT INCLUDE
THE TRANSITION OF THE STATE'S
ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORTING
PROCESS CAL. AB EIGHT ZERO FOUR
ADDRESSES THIS CONCERN. BY
REQUIRE THAT THE PROJECT NOT BE
THE COMPLETE AND SO ALL REQUIRED
AND SHE'S ARE USING PASCAL. AND
NOT BOULDER LEGACY SYSTEMS WITH
SOME EXCEPTIONS. WE ALSO
OBSERVED IN OUR MOST RECENT
MONITORING REPORT FROM THIS
JANUARY. THAT CISCO LIKE MANY
ENTITIES HAS CHALLENGES RELATED
TO HIRING AND RETAINING
SUFFICIENT STAFF TO SUPPORT
SYSTEM USERS. AND SECOND THAT
THE STATE HAS ISSUED ITS ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORTS INCREASING
POPULATION. WE NOTED THE TIMELY
REPORTING IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE TEACHING A HIGH CREDIT
RATING STAND. FOR ACCESS TO
FEDERAL FUNDS. AB EIGHT ZERO
WORK A TO INCLUDE IN ITS ANNUAL
REPORT PUBLISHED. INFORMATION ON
ITS VACANCIES AND ITS RECRUITING
EFFORTS. AND ON ENTITIES THAT
DID NOT PREPARE YEAR END
STATEMENTS USING A SCALE. BY THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE OF
DEADLINE. FINALLY IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE RECOMMENDED
THAT THE CONTRACT FOR
INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION
VALIDATION SERVICES ACCORDING
COMPONENT BUT LARGER I KEEP
PROJECTS. SHOULD RESIDE WITH
ANOTHER STATE ENTITY. SUCH AS
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
TO ENSURE THAT THE CONTRACTOR
REMAINS INDEPENDENCE OF THE
FISCAL PROJECT EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
KNOW FOR WOULD IMPLEMENT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS BY REQUIRING
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCIES
INSTEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT
CONTRACT FOR THESE SERVICES.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH LESS THAT'S YOUR ONLY A
PRIMARY WITNESS CORRECT ALL
RIGHT GREAT I IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO. PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. I SEE NINE FIVE OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. THAT
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE'LL CALL YOUR LINE
ONCE WE'RE READY TO WHAT YOU'RE
READING I AM SORRY OPERATOR I'M
I BELIEVE IT THAT THE BEGINNING
OF THE HEARING I PROVIDED- A-
ACCESS. AND ACCESS CODE FOR AN
EARLIER HEARING. US SO JUST TO
CONFIRM THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING. IS AS STATED.%
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. THAT IS CORRECT.
EVERITT SENATORS ARE WE ARE
GOING TO A UP AND GERMAN. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE I IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. C. NG NINE OPERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR ONCE
AGAIN WE HAVE KNOWN COMING UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I
WILL OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT C.
NINE WILL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
CHAT YOU'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND- APPRECIATE-
ALLOWING ME TO GO FIRST ALL
RIGHT WONDERFUL AND- I BELIEVE
WE DO AVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND PAUSE JUST TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. AND MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WANT TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALL RIGHT PETRIE
NORRIS. HERE PATTERSON. YEAH
PATTERSON BEARD GRAY. NO GREAT
LACKEY MEDINA. MEDINA RODRIGUEZ
NUMBER THREE YES AND- WENT.
IRWIN PRESENT WE HAVE A. ALL
RIGHT I TRAFFIC TO IN ORDER FOR
US TO ON ME THIS BILL FORWARD WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU I'M MOVED BY MR
PATTERSON SECONDED BY- IS IRWIN.
HI WITH THAT SECURITY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MARK PETRIE
NORRIS I. PATTERSON ALL RIGHT.
REYES ROCKY I. MEDINA RODRIGUEZ
AND IRWIN. OKAY ALL RIGHT GREAT
THAT BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON LIVING ON TO OUR NEXT
ITEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING OF
NOVEMBER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WHAT COLLEGE COULD BORI MY
PLEASURE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU
A BE NINETEEN NINETY SIX. WHICH
I AM. I AM ACTUALLY THRILLED TO
PRESENT TODAY. ALTHOUGH I'VE HAD
I DO KNOW THE BILL HAS DRAWN
SOME OPPOSITION BUT I ACTUALLY
THINK. HONESTLY I'VE I'VE IS
WITH MY- COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS CONVERSATION. AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS A SORT OF BILL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
PASSING BY ACCLAMATION. AND I
DEFINITELY DO NOT THINK FOR A
LOT OF REASONS. THAT TO ASK
STATE AGENCIES. ONE TIME TO LOOK
BASS BACK ACROSS THE THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THOUSAND PAGES
OF REGULATIONS AND CONSIDER
WHETHER SOMETHING IN THEIR IN
THEIR BAILIWICK MAYBE OUTDATED
INCONSISTENT DUPLICATIVE. IS
ASTONISHING. WE ARE HOWEVER THE
ONE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THAT
CONSTANTLY RENEWS ITSELF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH CONTINUES THE
COURTS CONTINUE BUT OUR BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT EVERY TWO YEARS WE
RENEW OURSELVES. AND AS A PART
OF THAT WE STAND DURING THE
CHAMBERS. WE STAND UP IN YOUR
WHICH ARE COUNTY IS CALLED. AND
WE TAKE THAT BASE THAT MOST
VULNERABLE. I DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR
TO SUPPORT. ATTORNEY TALK ABOUT
DEFENDING SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUTION. AND THERE'S
NOTHING MORE BASIC IN THE
CONSTITUTION AND THAT WE ARE THE
REPRESENT A BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
. THAT HOLDS THE PEOPLE'S CHARGE
. AND I FEEL THAT. I HAVE HAD
THIS BILL FOR A NUMBER OF TIMES
. BUT TOOK TO ME IT'S LIKE HOW
CAN WE LOOK AROUND THE GLOBE AND
NOT FEEL DEMOCRACY IS THREATENED
. EVEN OUR OWN NATION WE KNOW.
THE DEEP DIVISIONS THAT EXIST.
SO HOW DO WE HAVING TAKEN
THAT'LL- CONCEIVABLE WAY TO TELL
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE THAT OUR
DEMOCRACY IS NOT BROKEN. THAT
THERE IS A PATH IN THE STATE
CAPITAL THAT THE SYSTEM IS OPEN
TO PEOPLE. THEY WANT THE WINDOW
OPEN LET THE BREEZE BLOW. YOU
KNOW GOVERNMENT CANNOT LIVE BY
THE CREDO. COME WE'LL OR WILL
OUR STATUS IS QUO. THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE CAN BE ABOUT. IT'S NOT
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
ABOUT. TO MY CORE I BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS REASONABLE IF I WOULD
SAY IF THERE IS A ONE MAN- I
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED IN
TALKING ABOUT. IT UP THIS BILL
SAYS EVERY AGENCIES SHALL LOOK
BACK FOR THE SNOW CLASS OF A-
REGULATIONS OUTDATED DUPLICATIVE
INCONSISTENT. THEY WILL HOLD A
HEARING AND LET THE PEOPLE
COMMENT ON THAT SO THEY'RE OPEN
THE DOOR LED TO R. PARTIS POURED
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY
PARTICIPATE. THEY'RE GONNA
RICHARD REPORT THE LEGISLATURE
TO THE RELEVANT STANDING
COMMITTEES INFORMING THEM OF
SUGGESTED CHANGES. THERE'S A
THIRTY DAY WINDOW ON THAT REPORT
BEFORE THEY CAN ACT. WE MIGHT
SAY THAT IT SHOULD BE LONGER
THAN THIRTY DAYS. IT WAS DONE
THE BOOK FOR TEN YEARS I WOULD
THINK THERE'S SOME INCONSISTENCY
ONE A LOT OF THE SIXTIES WHEN A
LOT OF THE NINETY DAYS SO THE
COMMITTEES CAN ACTUALLY FOCUS ON
THAT. AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
STAKE IN WHETHER THAT'S A RIGHT
CALL THE SCRIPT READERS MIGHT
BE. A COULD WEIGH IN. BUT THE
LEGISLATURE RESPONSE- BUT I
DEFINITELY FEEL THAT THIS BILL.
I THINK IT MEETS A NEED IN OUR
ERA. YOU KNOW I WE ALL THANK YOU
ALL OF THE- BECAUSE HAD BY SIXTY
NINTH BIRTHDAY ON FRIDAY. I TELL
MY STAFF- MOLDS DIRT- I REMEMBER
WHEN I WAS EIGHT WRITE IN A
LETTER TO THE JFK WHITE HOUSE I
GOT A LETTER BACK. SOME SERVER
THAT CAMELOT GENERATION. YOU
KNOW WHAT AND EXCITEMENT. DID
WAS CREATED FROM THAT
PRESIDENTIAL RACE. AND THEN
BEFORE I WAS ELECTED OFFICIAL
LIKE. LESS THAN TWO WEEKS BEFORE
I TOOK MY FIRST OF OFFICES CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER. I GOT A LETTER
FROM ANOTHER KENNEDY. THIS ONE
U. S. SUPREME COURT JUSTICE TONY
KENNEDY. WHO WROTE ME A LETTER
AND HE SAID THE FOLLOWING.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND ALL
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR WORKING
TO RE INVIGORATE THE PRINCIPLE.
A PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY. SELF
GOVERNMENT LET'S NOT BE AN
ABSTRACT IDEAL BUT MUST BE A
REALITY. AND WE MUST BE
UNCEASING AND OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE IT MORE EFFECTIVE AND
RESPECTED BY OUR PEOPLE.
COLLEAGUES I LOOK AT THIS BILL
JUST SAYS A ONE TIME LOOK. FOR
THINGS OF A VERY NARROW CLASS.
TO SEE IF THEY MIGHT BE UPDATED.
TO MORE FOR. ACCURATELY REFLECT
THE HOW THE WHOLE SYSTEM WORK
THIS TO ME IS JUST A STRATEGY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE THIS
CONTINUALLY RENEWING INSTITUTION
TO TAKE A STEP TO MAKE OUR
PARTIS PORTABLE DEMOCRACY MORE
RESPECTED. I REALLY THINK WE ARE
IN AN ERA. WHEN EVERY LAWMAKER
EVERY PUBLIC OFFICIAL REALLY HAS
TO CONCENTRATE ON HOW DO WE MAKE
OUR SYSTEMS ARE INTERESTED
GOVERNMENT MORE RESPECTED. BY
OUR PEOPLE. AND- SO AS I SAY
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE STATE IS
TO REVIEW ALL OF ITS REGULATIONS
AND DIGNIFIED REVISED IN THE
THAT ARE DUPLICATIVE OVERLAPPING
INCONSISTENT RUN DATE. THERE'S A
TIMELINE FOR THIS THANK JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY SIX. I DO I
WELL KNOW THAT THE OFFICE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW REQUIRES A
REVIEW AT THE OUTSET. I WENT TO
WORK IN THE BILL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN RIGHT AFTER OIL
HAVE BEEN SET UP IT WAS THAT IT
WAS A- KEY KEYSTONE OF SPEAKER
LOW MCCARTHY'S CAREER. THAT'S
WHY WOULD I GO BACK TO THAT DAY.
AW THIS ISONE THAT IS MORE AS I
SAY IT'S FOCUSED ON THE PASSAGE
OF TIME. AND AS I SAY I TO OUR
INSTITUTION. DEALS WITH THAT SO
MANY OF OUR BILLS ARE KIND OF
LOOKING STATUTES- SO I DO THINK
IT'S SUPPORTS ACCOUNTABILITY BUT
REALLY I THINK IT'S- A DAUNTING
TIME PASSES THINGS CHANGE.
PEOPLE WANT TO FEEL OUR SYSTEM
GOVERNOR'S RESPONSIVE I THINK
THIS IS. IT IS NOT A HEAVY LEFT
. THERE COULD BE A QUESTION AND
IT HAS BEEN RAISED BY SOME OF
THE CRITICS OF. ALL MY ALL MY
GOSH THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TAKE TIME AND RESOURCES TO DO
THIS REVIEW. AND SO IT SORT OF
BECOMES A QUESTION IS THAT THE
RIGHT. USE OF TIME NOW THERE'S
ACTUALLY A FAIR QUESTION.
RESOURCE ALLOCATION ISSUES ARE
ALWAYS IMPORTANT. BUT DOING IT
THROUGH THE LENS OF DEMOCRACY
AND HOW WE STRENGTHEN AND HOW WE
ESTABLISHED THAT WE ARE. FULL ON
. OKAY RESPONSIVE ACCOUNTABLE
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY I THINK
THIS ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE FOR
YEARS TO GET THROUGH IT IS NOT
TOO GREAT A BURDEN ACTUALLY THEY
GIVE ACTUALLY REBALANCES THE
SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT'S GOOD FOR
DEMOCRACY. ON SO THAT IS- MY
PRESENTATION- I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE IS THAT PROVISION.
WHICH GREW OUT OF MY
CONVERSATIONS OF LABOR ON THIS
BILL YEARS AGO BUT I WILL READ
INTO THE RECORD. THAT SAYS. THIS
CHAPTER SHALL NOT BE CONSTRUED
TO WEAKEN OR UNDERMINE THE
SECTION ELEVEN THREE SIXTY SIX
POINT FOUR FIVE. ON PAGE FOR THE
BILL THIS CHAPTER SHOULD NOT BE
CONSTRUED TO WEAKEN OR UNDERMINE
IN ANY MANNER IN HUMAN HEALTH
PUBLIC OR WORKER RIGHTS PUBLIC
WELFARE ENVIRONMENTAL OR OTHER
PROTECTIONIST ABSENT A STATUTE.
THIS CHAPTER SHOPPING CONSTRUED
AFFECT THE AUTHORITY OR
REQUIREMENT FOR NATURE TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS AS PROVIDED BY
STATUTE. RATHER IT IS THE INTENT
OF ALLEGED TO ENSURE THAT STATE
AGENCIES FOCUS MORE FOR FIND
DRUG UNDER DUTIES AS PRESCRIBED
BY LOSS WAS TOO SCARCE PUBLIC
DOLLARS FOR VIRTUALLY TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW WILL ACHIEVE
EQUAL OR IMPROVED ECONOMIC AND
PUBLIC BENEFITS. SO I. THAT OF
COURSE WAS PUT THERE TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT USING THIS REVIEW
. TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
CHARACTER FROM REGULATION IS
ACHIEVING A IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH OR OTHER PURPOSE. AND I
ACTUALLY THAT'S A SALVATOR
PROVISION THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
A RIGHT THING. SO I DO KNOW I AM
. JOIN TODAY BY- ASHLEY HOFFMAN
A POLICY ADVOCATE CALCHAMBER AND
I'M OF COURSE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
SUPPORT BUT THIS IS MY BILL.
THIS IS A BILL THAT I DRAFTED
IT'S NOT ONE THAT CAME FROM
ANYONE ELSE YOUR FAX FOR MY OWN
PERSONAL CONVICTIONS. AND- AND
AS I SAY IF I THOUGHT WAS A GOOD
IDEA IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN I
FIRST INTRODUCED AS A B. TWELVE
AND PASSED BY ACCLAMATION. I
ACTUALLY FEEL MEETS AN EVEN MORE
PRESSING NEED NOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CLAY. I OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR-
MISS HOFFMAN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ACTUALLY
HAWKS IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY NINETEEN
NINETY SIX MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESSES ARE SMALL BUSINESS
SAID AND MORE THAN 80% OF THEM
HAD FEWER THAN TEN EMPLOYEES.
THE SMALL BUSINESSES DO NOT HAVE
THE SAME FINANCIAL ABILITY IS A
LARGE BUSINESS TO RETAIN LEGAL
COUNSEL ACCOUNTANT OR EMPLOYER
ABOUT HUMAN RESOURCES DEPARTMENT
I'VE TALKED TO MANY WHERE THE
OWNERS THEMSELVES ARE THE ONES
RUNNING PAYROLL AND BALANCING
THE BOOKS IN ADDITION TO THEIR
OTHER DUTIES. THESE LIMITED
RESOURCES MAKE IT EXCEPTIONALLY
DIFFICULT TO KEEP UP WITH
CALIFORNIA'S EVER GROWING BODY
OF LAWS AND REGULATIONS AND HOW
THOSE LAWS ARE BEING ENFORCED
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO DENT
MULTIPLE PAGE CONTENT HUNDREDS
OF PAGES BONTA REGULATION AND
THE LABOR CONTEXT THERE'S BEEN
INSTANCES WHERE AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
IS FOR CALIFORNIA TO UPDATE ITS
OWN OUT OF EIGHT REGULATIONS TO
CONFORM TO UPDATE SIMILAR
FEDERAL REGULATION WHICH COULD
GENERATE COMPLAINTS ISSUES AND
CONFUSION. BY REQUIRING STATE
AGENCIES TO PROACTIVELY CONDUCT
A ONE TIME INTERNAL REPEAL SEVEN
DENNIS HI INCONSISTENT
OVERLAPPING ARE OUT OF STATE
REGULATIONS THIS BILL WILL HELP
OUR SMALL BUSINESS BETTER WHAT
IS REQUIRED OF THEM THIS
EXERCISE WOULD BE ESPECIALLY
MEANINGFUL AT A TIME AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE GETTING BACK ON
THEIR FEET AFTER SUFFERING
HISTORICAL FINANCIAL DEVASTATION
DURING CARPET. THE FACT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS HAD TO ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS RUN BILLS TO
REQUIRE AGENCIES TO UPDATE
SPECIFIC REGULATIONS- IDENTIFIED
INCONSISTENT POLICIES
REGULATIONS DEMONSTRATE THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS INDEED
WARRANTED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. IN THE URGENT I
ABOUT. THANK YOU. I IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TEST AND. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
TWO CLIENTS THE HOLLYWOOD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
. PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DATE FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. IRATE AT SO WITH THAT
WE WILL MOVE TO OUR OUT
WITNESSES WHO ARE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION FIVE.
LET'S SEE- DO WE HAVE FOLKS IN
THE ROOM TODAY YES WE DO ALL
RIGHT SO WE ARE FIVE GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM MITCH STICKER- FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH STEIGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- AS WELL INTENTIONED AND
SENSIBLE AS THE BILL MAY SOUND
WE BELIEVE THAT. THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN IN AFFECT WOULD BE
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT. WE
BELIEVE THAT BY FAR THE BIGGEST
WEAKNESS IN OUR CURRENT
REGULATORY STRUCTURE IS THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IT TAKES.
FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO WORKER SAFETY STANDARDS
IT TAKES ON AVERAGE SIX TO TEN
YEARS OR MORE. FOR A NEW
STANDARD TO TAKE A FACT AND WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS REQUIRE
THOSE WERE DEVELOPING THOSE
REGULATIONS TO ESSENTIALLY DROP
WHAT THEY'RE DOING GO BACK
THROUGH ALL OF THE EXISTING
TITLE A RAGS. AND LOOK FOR
OVERLAPPING OR DUPLICATIVE FOR
AND CONSISTENT LANGUAGE AND WHAT
THAT WOULD DO I MEAN WE ALREADY
SEE. THAT CREATE A LOT OF DELAYS
WHEN THEY HAVE TO DROP WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND MOVE ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE BUT BY REQUIRING
THEM TO GO THROUGH EVERY SINGLE
REGULATION THAT'S IN PLACE. IT
WOULD OUT WHO KNOWS HOW MUCH
TIME BUT IT WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
WORKERS ALREADY WAIT FAR TOO
LONG SUFFER INJURIES IN SOME
CASES FATALITIES WHILE WAITING
FOR THE STANDARDS TO TAKE A
FACT. THIS BILL WOULD JUST
EXTEND THAT AMOUNT OF TIME WE'RE
VERY WORRIED ABOUT THAT. IN
ADDITION PART OF THE REASON THAT
IT TAKES SO LONG IS THAT THESE
AGENCIES SPEND A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME OBSESSING OVER THE LANGUAGE
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT DOESN'T
ALREADY DUPLICATE EXISTING
STANDARDS OR EXISTING REGULATORY
LANGUAGE. AND SO BY REQUIRING
THEM TO GO BACK THROUGH AND
ESSENTIALLY DO THAT AGAIN
IRONICALLY THIS BILL KIND OF
CREATES THE EXACT PROBLEM IS
TRYING TO SOLVE. AND THEN
FINALLY PROBABLY OUR BIGGEST
CONCERN IS THAT. A LOT OF
REASONABLE MINDS DISAGREE OVER
WHAT QUALIFIES AS INCONSISTENT
OR DUPLICATIVE LANGUAGE
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKER SAFETY STANDARDS THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY ARGUES THAT.
EVERY SINGLE NEW STANDARD THAT
WE PETITION FOR OR SUPPORT
DUPLICATES WHAT'S CALLED THE
INJURY AND ILLNESS PREVENTION
PROGRAM. EVERY SINGLE ONE THAT
I'VE WORKED ON MY TIME
CALIFORNIA THEY'VE MADE THIS
ARGUMENT AND THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD STOP THEM
FROM LITIGATING THIS QUESTION.
WILL BE IN EFFECT. QALISYA
DIDN'T AGREE AND IDENTIFY A
VARIETY OF REGULATIONS AS BEING
DUPLICATIVE FOR THE EMPLOYER
COMMITTEES MADE IT VERY CLEAR.
THAT THEY BELIEVE ESSENTIALLY
ALL OF THESE NEW STANDARDS
DUPLICATE THE IPP AND THAT'S
JUST ONE AGENCY REALLY WITH ONE
ISSUE AREA IT'S BOGGLES THE MIND
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THIS WOULD
LOOK LIKE ACROSS ALL STATE
AGENCIES SO. WE VERY MUCH DUE
RESPECT INTENT WE THINK THE
REALITY WOULD JUST MEAN GREATER
DELAYS THE HER MORE WORKERS. AND
A VARIETY OF OTHER PROBLEMS AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE URGENT OVER
. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OUT
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL WITNESS-
IN OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE ON THE
OPERATOR CAN OPEN THE PHONE LINE
FOR- MS LINDA SAID I'D LIKE WE.
GOOD MORNING WHERE MEMBERS WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER AMMAN
COPY YOU MUST UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSE AB NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S GOLDBERG
BELIEVES THE BILL IS UNNECESSARY
AS MENTIONED THE EXISTING
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
ALREADY INCLUDES SEVERAL BASS
PROCESS. TO ENSURE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS ARE NECESSARY NOT
DUPLICATE IT IN CLEAR MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE ACT ENSURE A
STRONG PUBLIC COMMENT PROCESS BY
PROVIDING STAKEHOLDERS AMPLE
TIME AND NOTICE TO ENGAGE. AND-REQUIRING AGENCIES TO RESPOND TO
PUBLIC COMMENT RATHER THAN
DIVERTING RESOURCES WE WOULD
RATHER STATE AGENCIES PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS NOTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WHICH OVERSEES THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM HAVE YET TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS. FOR CHANGES IN
STATUTE OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO
RATHER THAN ELIMINATING
REGULATIONS WITH LIMITED PUBLIC
INPUT PROCESS WE RECOMMEND
PUSHING AGENCIES REGULATIONS
DEADLINE BY IMPORTING STATE
STATUTE. FINALLY WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ENCOURAGE STATE AGENCY TEAM
SEPARADO. TORY CADENCE. HELLO
REVIEW AND IT'S NOT AS ROBERT AT
THE PRODUCT. WOULD BE TO BE
THINKING WE RESPECT OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM I WISH SHE CHIU.
TESTIFY IN A- OKAY NINE
OPERATORS ANYONE ON ON THE PHONE
LINE TO IN OPPOSITION. IF ANYONE
IS TEST IN A PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE A LINE CHEWED UP ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE DEADLINE NUMBER. WE WILL GO TO LINE TWELVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MAKERS FLANK THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION OR
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THANK YOU.
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR LACKEY.
YEAH I JUST REAL BRIEFLY WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT YOU'RE OPENING
PRESENTATION WAS JUST MISSING
PATRIOTIC MUSIC IN THE
BACKGROUND WAS A SO WELL STATED-
I CAN TELL YOU THAT- YEAH YOU.
YOUR WISDOM IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED AS REFLECTED IN THIS
BILL AND PROUD TO SUPPORT.
MISTER K. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
THANK YOUR SQUADRONS BEFORE I
THINK IT HAS A LOT OF MERIT-
ALTHOUGH I DID THINK THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE GENTLEMAN
FROM LABOR SHED- BROUGHT UP SOME
GOOD ISSUES MOST NOTABLY IN MY
MIND- BECAUSE THE RESOURCES
ISSUE RIGHT TO OFTEN THE
AGENCIES THAT WE PUT IN CHARGE
OF OVERSIGHT ESSENTIALLY ORDER
OR REGULATION- ARE UNDERFUNDED
AND IN FACT THIS LEGISLATURES
PASSED SOME PRETTY HORRIFIC
BILLS THAT TURNED THE OVERSIGHT
OF STATE GOVERNMENT AND SOME OF
THESE YOUR WORKER PROTECTIONS
ARE THINGS OVER THE COURTS.
RIGHT WHAT WE TEND TO INCOMING
OVERLY LITIGIOUS SOCIETY WHERE
WE TEND TO- LITIGATORS PROBLEMS
WITH THE EXCUSE ALL WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES WELL IN THE
LAST. GOSH I DON'T KNOW FOR FIVE
YEARS NOW I AM HAVING A HARD
TIME REMEMBER NEW YEAR WE DIDN'T
HAVE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS IT. MAYBE SOME OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS TO HELP ME OUT. SO
TO ME. THE RIGHT WAY FORWARD
HERE AND I KNOW THE LABOR FED.
REPRESENTATIVE WONDERED IN THIS
BECAUSE THEY'RE OFTEN SAY HEY WE
GOT A WORK IN PROGRESS BILL HERE
WE NEED TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
THERE'S SOME PROBLEMS. MAYBE WE
NEED TO ENGAGE SOME. PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN YOU AND THE FOLKS AT THE
LABOR FED- SO THAT WE COULD GET
INTO THE RESOURCES ISSUE BECAUSE
I DON'T SEE HOW ONE. ELIMINATES
THE OPTION FOR THE OTHER RIGHT
HAVING THE ABILITY GO BACK AND
LOOK AT TO PLAY COULD HAVE A
REGULATIONS DEAL WITH US WHILE
THAT MIGHT TAKE MORE RESOURCES
WE STILL NEED THE UMPIRES ON THE
FIELD GREAT POINT LET'S MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE ROUTE. IS A TO
DO THAT WORK AND I'M SURE- THE
LABOUR FED IN YOUR OFFICE TO
PERHAPS GET TOGETHER WORK ON
SOME AMENDMENTS OR OR SOME
PROPOSALS FOR THE NEXT COMMITTEE
HEARINGS WHERE WE COULD GET THE
MONEY AND THEY COULD BECOME
CHAMPIONS OF THIS EFFORT MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE MONEY BOTH
TO DO OUR CURRENT JOB. ABOUT
ALSO HAVE THE RESOURCES TO LOOK
AT A JUDGE DUPLICATIVE.
REGULATIONS THAT MAKES LESS
SENSE TO ME SO I'M CURIOUS IF
YOU'D BE OPEN TO MAYBE HAVE SOME
MEETINGS WITH THEM AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE ALL MOVE IN A
DIRECTION THAT'S PRODUCTIVE AND
DON'T LET. TO- YOU KNOW TO
POSITIVE CONCEPTS- DIE. BECAUSE
OF A LACK OF COOPERATION WHAT DO
YOU THINK YEAH. WELL I THINK
MOST MOST PEOPLE THINK THAT IF
YOU BELIEVE IN SOMETHING YOU PUT
MONEY BEHIND. STRUCTURE THAT
THAT IS A RIGHT SORT OF MESSAGE
TO BE SENDING. IT THAT SAYS IT
IS A PRIORITY ON. I THINK THE-
IN THEIR PROCESS I THINK THE
OPPORTUNITY OF COURSES BILL JUST
FOCUS ON DUPLICATIVE
INCONSISTENT OUTDATED. AHA
ACTUALLY THAT'LL END UP BEING AN
ERROR CLASS OF THINGS BUT I. THE
IDEA OF KIND OF PROVIDING SOME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE PROCESS I
THINK IS GOOD I ALSO WANNA NOTE
AGAIN THIS PROVISION IT.
AGENCIES AS HE IDENTIFIED THE
SORTS OF ISSUES OUR FIRST REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON WHAT THE
CEASE AND THAT WOULD GO TO THE
STANDING COMMITTEE SO. I'VE
ALREADY SUGGEST I THINK. AS
DRAFTED THE BILL PROVIDES THAT
THEY PROVIDE A THIRTY DAY
NOTICE. AND I ACTUALLY THINK.
LISTING TO THEM TO HAVE IT
ILLEGIBLE MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS
ALLOWS A LITTLE MORE
CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN AND
PEOPLE LOOK OVER THE SHOULDER
AGAIN OF THE OF THE AGENCY ARE
THEY GOING DOWN THE RIGHT TRAIL
DO WE AGREE WITH THAT SO I'M
ACTUALLY RECEPTIVE ON THE
FUNDING SIDE I THINK THAT
ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT THERE BE. IT
IS A PRIORITY AND I ALSO THINK
THE WAY IT'S STRUCTURED NOW IT
WOULD DOVETAIL WITH THAT.
PRESSURE THE PRESSURE THAT WOULD
LOVE A FEW A FEW OFFICE KEEP ME
UPDATED ON. KIND OF THE STATUS
OF DISCUSSIONS IN THE LAST
LABOUR FED- I WILL BRING YOU UP
HERE AGAIN BUT- IF YOU CAN KEEP
ME POSTED ON YOUR PARTICIPATION
AS WELL. THANK YOU WELL I MR
COOLEY YOU BROUGHT THIS BILL
FORWARD IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
I WAS A NEWLY ELECTED MEMBER
JERRY I THINK PROBABLY MY FIRST
HEARING OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I
REMEMBER LOOKING BACK THROUGH
THE HISTORY OF IT THIS PROPOSAL
AND I THINK I PROBABLY SAID IN
THE HEARING I WAS COMPLETELY
CONFOUNDED BY THE FACT THAT. IT
HAD FAILED SO MANY TIMES TO MOVE
THROUGH OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND BE ENACTED INTO LAW AND I
THINK LOOKING BACK AND IF YOU
KNOW THREE YEARS ON TO MY TIME
THE LEGISLATURE I FEEL THAT A
MEASURE LIKE THIS IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN I THOUGHT IT WAS
AS A NEW MEMBER IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND I THINK FOR ME WANT
ONE EXAMPLE THAT I DO WANT TO
SHARE BECAUSE IT WAS AN AREA
THAT THIS COMMITTEE I SPENT A
LOT OF TIME AND ATTENTION ON
AND- ALSO AN ISSUE THAT WAS.
WIDELY IN THE NEWS THAT'S
RELATED TO YOU CALIFORNIA'S EDT
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ANDFOR ME THAT
DEPARTMENT JUST TYPIFIES WHY
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT. AND WHY. APPLE THIS
HAS A REAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS SO. AS WE CONDUCT
OUR OVERSIGHT HEARINGS INTO E.
D. D. WE LEARNED THAT EDIE'S
TRAINING MANUAL. IS AN EIGHT
HUNDRED. EIGHT HUNDRED PAGE
PAPER DOCUMENTS. AND I'M SORRY
BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA TELL ME
THAT IN THAT EIGHT HUNDRED PAGE
PAPER DOCUMENT THERE IS NOT HECK
OF A LOT OF. AMAZING THAT WOULD
OUTDATED REDUNDANT AND
DUPLICATIVE LEGISLATION WHICH IS
WHY IT MAKES IT SO DIFFICULT.
FOR OUR HARD WORKING EMPLOYEES
AT ET DE. TAKE GET THEIR JOB
DONE AND GET MONEY INTO THE
HANDS OF CALIFORNIANS THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED PAGE MANUAL ALSO SAYS IT
SPEAKS TO A OUTDATED LEGACY
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS WHICH GUESS
WHAT. WE'RE SPENDING LESS TIME
AND ENERGY ON OUT AIDED IN
DUPLICATIVE REGULATIONS WE'VE
GOT MORE TIME ENERGY AND MONEY.
TO FIX THE UNDERLYING TECHNOLOGY
ISSUESI'M AND THEN THE LAST
POINT I WANT TO PICK UP BECAUSE
I THOUGHT IT WAS YOU AS MR
LACKEY NOTED DURING YOUR OPENING
WAS WAS VERY POWERFUL. AND YOU
MADE A CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
SPELL TO ADDRESS. OUTDATED I
DUPLICATE EVERY TENDONS
REGULATIONS TO THE STREET. TO
MARK SAY. AND I THINK THAT
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW. THAT'S A
CONNECTION THOSE ARE OTS PEOPLE
DO NOT ALWAYS CAN ACT BUT- I
COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE I
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE IN A AND
WHERE. I PEOPLE'S FAITH IN
GOVERNMENT. THAT SOMETHING OF AN
ALL TIME LOW AND THAT IS WHY I
THINK THAT THE ROLE OF OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IS MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER BECAUSE
EVERY TIME THERE'S A STORY.
ABOUT WASTE FRAUD OR ABUSE IT OF
REDS THE PUBLIC'S TRUST FURTHER
AND- IT IS IMPERATIVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE FOR ALL OF US TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
RESTORE PEOPLE'S FAITH IN
GOVERNMENT. AND DELIVER FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I JUST TAKE THE
PROVISION BEING HERE RIGHT I
THANK THIS COMMITTEE I. SO
DEEPLY BELIEVE IN OVERSIGHT. AND
THE ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE
EVERYBODY DOES OVERSIGHT BUT SO
OFTEN BIG DOLLAR ISSUES GET
REVIEWED IN THIS COMMITTEE IT
PLAYS A VERY VITAL ROLE IN HOW
OUR GOVERNMENT WORKS SO OFTEN IN
THE TECHNOLOGY AREA. THERE'S SO
MUCH OVERSIGHT TO GETS DONE HERE
BUT- I DO BELIEVE THIS IDEA I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE VERY
FINE ANALYSIS WAS PERFORMED. I
SAID IN MY REMARKS IN TWENTY
ELEVEN CENTER FRAN PAVLEY HAD
THIS IDEA IN A BILL. AND I WANT
TO NOTE THAT- IN THE COMMENTS ON
THE BILL IS STATED THE APPROACH
IN THIS BILL IS IN LINE WITH A
RECOMMENDATION. FROM THE TWENTY
ELEVEN LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
REPORT BETTER REGULATION
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S RULE
MAKING PROCESS WHICH STATES THAT
THE STATE SHOULD CREATE A LOOK
BACK MECHANISM. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER REGULATIONS ARE STILL
NEEDED AND WHETHER THEY WORK. SO
I THINK THAT'S SORT OF IN. A
LOOK BACK MECHANISM MR- GRAYSON
WAS LIKE SOMETHING WOULD HAVE
SOME FUNDED WITH SO- I THINK. I
WILL CONCLUDE I THINK THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING HERE. AND I
DEFINITELY WANT TO SAY. MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SIDE WHO ARE
WHO TODAY ARE NOT STATE IN
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. NONE THE
LESS ARE PART OF OUR
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY I WILL
LOOK FORWARD WITH WORKING WITH
THEM. AND- BUT IN THE DAY I FEEL
MY JOB IS TO BE A CHAMPION FOR
THE PEOPLE AND FOR. THIS
INSTITUTION WHICH IS. AS I SAY
ONE WHICH RENEWS ITSELF AND I
THINK THIS IS PART. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. MOVE ALL RIGHT
AND THE SECOND. THE SECOND RIGHT
THANK YOU AT MISSION FOR MR
PATTERSON A SECOND FROM MR
LACKEY ON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS I SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON ALL
RIGHT GREAT. LACKEY HI MEDINA
NOT VOTING MEDINA MONNING
RODRIGUEZ MOBILE RODRIGUEZ NOT
VOTING AND IRWIN HI- IRWIN HI.
RIGHT THAT FELL IS DON'T AND
THANK YOU MR COOLEY. ALL RIGHT
AB MOVING TO OUR LAST A BILL
PRESENTATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
THE BILL OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX MOVE THE BILL
PATRIOTIC BILL SINCE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PATRIOTIC BILLS
TODAY- I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING US-
FIX A DRAFTING ERROR THAT WAS IN
THE BILL- IT'S VERY SIMPLE-
STRAIGHT FOR A BILL THAT WOULD
ADD RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS TO DISTRICTS THAT CAN
QUALIFY FOR THE PROMPT PAY-
PROVISIONS THE SAME WAY THAT
SMALL BUT- SMALL BUSINESSES- DO
SAID THEY RECEIVE THE PAYMENT
TODAY RIGHTFULLY DESERVE AND
JUST REALLY QUICKLY OUR CD'S-
HERE MANY OF YOU HAVE WORKED
WITH THEM THERE- CRITICAL. THAT
DISTRICTS THAT HELP WITH-
AGRICULTURE- WITH RESOURCES BEEN
BURIED THE INSTRUMENTAL IN MY
DISTRICT HELPING WITH- WILDFIRE
AND PREVENTION AND FUELS
MANAGEMENT- PROJECTS- SO- JUST
ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I AND
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU HAVE ONE-
PERSON ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY
AND THAT'S VICKY DAWLEY WILL.
WITH THE TAME A COUNTY RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT RIGHT I
OPERATOR KEY PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR- IS DOLLY. THIS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THANKS FOR HAVING ME- THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
OF TEHAMA COUNTY MANAGES ABOUT
FIFTY PROJECTS THAT RANGE FROM
FOUR STRAIGHT EDUCATION ACT OUR
CULTURE WE ARE SOLD THE GRANT
FUNDED LIKE THE MAJORITY OF OUR
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE. IT'S
LEADERS DEPENDING ON
REIMBURSABLE GRANTS WHICH MEANS
THAT WE SPEND THE MONEY AND THEN
WE GET PREPARED FOR THE WORK IF
THAT REPAYMENT IS SLOW IT CAN
CAUSE SERIOUS FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS. ON MANY OCCASIONS
WE'VE HAD TO WAIT SIX MONTHS FOR
PAYMENT AND THREE MONTHS IS A
STANDARD PAYMENT SCHEDULE. WHERE
ARE STATE CONTRACT UNLIKE THE
FORTY FIVE DAY PAYMENT SCHEDULE
THAT IS WRITTEN IN ALL OF OUR
STATE CONTRACTS THAT FORTY FIVE
DAY PAYMENT SCHEDULES RARELY
MATH. DURING THE BOND FREEZE OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAD TO LAY
OFF 5850% OF OUR STAFF WHILE WE
WAITED FOR THE STATE TO START.
PAYING US AGAIN AND- WHEN
AGENCIES WERE CONVERTING TO
CRISCO WE WENT FOR TWO MONTHS
WITH NO PAYMENTS WHATSOEVER AND
WE'RE VERY CLOSE TO HAVING TO
LAY OFF STAFF AGAIN AND THAT
WAS. JUST A COUPLE YEARS AGO. WE
HAVE A STAFF OF TWENTY AND
EQUIPMENT THE CONDUCTOR FIELD
WORK WHICH INCLUDES PICKUP
TRUCKS TO CHIPPERS TO
MASTICATING HERS. AND IT'S SORT
OF SMALL EQUIPMENT AND TOOLS.
SOME OF OUR PROJECTS THAT
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT ASSISTANCE
TO THE RESIDENTS OF THE HAMMOCK
COUNTY ARE- PROVIDING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AROUND HOMES. THE ELDERLY
LOW INCOME AND DISABLED
CITIZENS. BUILDING ROADSIDE FUEL
BREAKS PROVIDING FREE IRRIGATION
EFFICIENCY EVALUATIONS TO
GROWERS IN THE GRAND BE TO HIM
AND SHASTA COUNTIES. IN
CONSTRUCTING SIDE CHANNELS FOR
WINTER RUN SALMON HABITAT
INCLUDING THE LARGEST BY CHANNEL
SACRAMENTO RIVER. SO YOU CAN SEE
WE PROVIDE A LOT OF SERVICES
AND- A LOT OF. VARIETY ALL THE
GRANT FROM THE ORGANISED IT'S
DIFFICULT TO GET LINES OF
CREDIT. WHICH WOULD HELP
ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEM OF SMALL
PAY BANKS ARE RELUCTANT TO OFFER
LINES OF CREDIT ORGANIZATIONS
WHO OFTEN HAVE NO ASSETS AND
INCOME STREAM THAT'S NOT
CONSISTENT. APPLE WE TRIED TO
INCREASE OUR FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR LINE OF CREDIT WHEN OUR
ANNUAL BUDGET WITH A MILLION
DOLLARS BUT WITHOUT A GUARANTEED
INCOME. NONE OF THE FOUR BANKS
WE CAN HELP AND WAS WILLING TO
FUND IT. TO PROTECT OUR ABILITY
TO MEET OUR OWN PAYROLL ANY
AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE WITH
SUBCONTRACTORS INCLUDE A
PROVISION OF THE SUBCONTRACTOR
DOESN'T GET PAID UNTIL THE RCD
GETS PAID. THIS LEAVES MALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN A DIFFICULT
POSITION AS THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
PAYROLL AND SUBCONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS AND IT MEANS THAT
SOME CONTRACTORS CANNOT AND WILL
NOT AFFORD TO DO BUSINESS WITH
THE RCD. WE FOUND THAT SOME
STATE AGENCIES ARE MORE RELIABLE
YOUR ABILITY TO PAY AND I AM THE
MATTER WE AND POTENTIAL BIDDERS
ARE PROJECTS ARE RELUCTANT TO
WORK WITH THOSE THAT WE KNOW ARE
SLOW PAYERS. ALTHOUGH STATE
AGENCIES OF ALL CONVERTED TO
FISCAL NOW THE STATE HAS REACHED
A SOLUTION FOR PAYING OUT
FUNDING FROM BONDS. THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE BOUNDARIES
PROBLEM. AND SEVERAL AGENCIES
ARE NOW ALLOWING ADVANCE IS NOT
GRANT FUNDING. WE ARE
CONTINUALLY AT RISK OF SOME NEW
CATASTROPHE THAT WILL SLOW OR
HALT THE PAYMENTS ON OUR STATE
GRANTS. WE BELIEVE SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX WOULD
ALLEVIATE MUCH OF THIS CONCERN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SEEN NINE OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE. ON THE LINE- WISHING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME. HEARING NONE I ANYONE IN THE
ROOM SHE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. C. NINE OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THAT PHONE LINES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
. TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE COULD NOT MADAM
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLASS IT IS ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
I WE HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER
GRAY SECOND FOR MR PATTERSON AYE
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS I BETWEEN NORTH
AYE PATTERSON PERSON I GREAT.
GREAT AYE LACKING AYE HEAT AYE
MEDINA MEDINA HI RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I AND- WENT- WHEN I
SEVEN ZERO THAT BELL IS OUT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER. AND AS WITH THAT I
BELIEVE THAT IS THE END OF OUR
BUSINESS TODAY OUT WE- WILL NOW
ADJOURN THIS HEARING OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- THANK YOU.
GET ANOTHER REST STATE THANK YOU
MR GREAT LEADS THAT WE DO NEED
TO ADD. REVIT VIEW I BELIEVE THE
ROLE FOR FIVE. MISTER SALAS TO
ENABLE MEMBERS TO ADD ON MADAM
SECRETARY. HELLO. OKAY THE GREAT
GREAT I MEDINA. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. MEANS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU AND AT WITH THAT AT
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.
RIGHT.